[Peter] Given 2 strings, s and t, we want to print out udacious
without using any quotes, and we're going to do that
by using the subsequence operator, the colon.
Let's say we want to get the first 5 characters from s
and the last 3 from t.
Since we want to print our result out,
we need the print statement, and let's print our s part first.
We want to go from the beginning, so we're just going to put the colon there,
and we want to go 0, 1, 2, 3, 4.
Since we want to include the fourth character,
we're going to go end it at 5.
Now we want the rest to come from t, which are the last 3 characters.
So we're not going to want to start at the beginning.
We want to start at 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6th character.
And we want to go to the end.
This will print out udacious without using any quotes, as you can see.
But there's another solution if you're a true Python guru.
Let's go to the interpreter to try that out.
We have our 2 strings, s and t.
Let's say you're like me, and you don't like counting above the number 4.
And we still want to solve this problem without using any quotes.
So we're going to have our print, and we're going to use
everything but the last 2 characters and s, as we did before.
And since we know all we want is everything but the last 2 characters,
we can just type in -2.
This gives us--the first part, we had an s,
but without having to count 1 character at a time until the end.
Let's do this same thing with t.
Here we have a little different problem.
We want to start with the last 3 characters.
We're going to use the same negative notation
and go all the way to the end.
This gives us our 2 parts,
so all we have to do is combine them.
And we get this result without having to count really at all.